القلق ليس مقتصرا على النواب الاربعه لجنه
لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه تحقق منذ 2011 مع
تويتر لكن كثفت هذه التحقيقات بعد استحواذ
ماسك اللجنه طلبت من المنصه توضيحات حول
ما اذا كانت تمتلك الموارد اللازمه او
الفريق الكافي للامتثال لاتفاقيه الخصوصيه
وبحسب تصريحات احد المطلعين على التفاصيل
لوكاله رويترز وان ثبتت انتهاكات المنصه
قد تواجه غرامات بمليارات الدولارات من
لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه لكن ايلون ماسك
لا يخاف من اللجنه فهو يضع الصواريخ في
الفضاء هكذا يرى الامر اليكسبيرو محامي
ماسك التحقيق الذي تجريه لجنه التجاره
الفيدراليه مع ماسك يواجهه انتقادات
تحديدا من الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
واللجنه القضائيه التي يتراسها الجمهوري
ظهر هذا الامر جليا في مارس الماضي جلسه
الاستماع كانت صاخبه في مبنى الحضاراتها
رئيسه اللجنه لنخان واللجنه القضائيه بحثت
مزاعم بان لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه اساءت
استخدام سلطتها النتيجه كانت تقريرا من
ثماني عشره صفحه اتهم فيها الجمهوريون
اتهم فيها الجمهوريون لجنه التجاره بتنظيم
حمله لمهاجمه تويتر التقرير اشار الى ان
هذا التحقيق جاء نتيجه لضغط حزبي والهدف
استهداف تويتر واسكاتو ماسك التقرير رفضه
المتحدث باسم لجنه التجاره الفيدراليه
دوجلاس فارير التحقيقات مباشره وليست
سياسيه
[موسيقى]
اشد والجذب والملاحقات لماسك ليست الوحيده
الملياردير الامريكي محاصر بالتهم هذه
المره بشان العملات الرقميه
مجموعه من المستثمرين اقترحوا رفع دعوه
جمعيه ضد ماسك بتهمه التلاعب بهذه
العمليات ورفع سعرها عمدا باكثر من سته
وثلاثين الفا في المئه على مدار عامين ثم
تركها تنهار وما كلفهم مليارات الدولارات
استخدم ماسك في ذلك عده وسائل منشورات
تويتر منها لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات